let's let's just break this question so
you can think in a higher power of
actually going to get out of this
expansion will be this hierarchy will be
five so therefore when you put them
together the highest power will be
eleven right are there or you're picking
up on this it alone sure okay yeah I am
fish will get it okay I'm going to write
down what is this thing going to give me
and then what is this thing going to
give me but I'm only going to look for
the particular ones that will give me a
combination that I want ok so here's one
of it I'll see this thing here right 3
minus X to the power of 6 okay
I am actually going to get in my head
what would the extension this be bit
okay so this is going to be let's see
I'm on the sixth row all concentratin
said that times these guys times these
guys they're like very very first time
that again and then I'm going to say the
next one 3 to the 5 one less of those
one more of those it's like okay um oh
my god I'm going to do it along so the
next time is 62 you get this gets a bit
more in middle it is not hard
okay I know exactly a structure of
baronial and then all are they do yep
to observe it you know how what it's
like a minus in the binomial you know
how like it's like every like second
number
yeah but like even dislike to stop
yourself getting confuse you put the
brackets around the minus eight just
like I love it
well then that's the brackets around the
minus R nothing why you have alternating
science right because you see this one
how many negatives are going to end up
in that term none how many [ __ ] are
going to be here once it'll be a - how
many is a here there are two which
cancel out which is white comes back to
plus okay all right another time 3q 2
minus X cubes okay okay yeah doesn't
done I can't continue right I'm going to
pause there this is what happens when I
extend left head side or the left here
binary when I extend the right hand back
review what happens from the data its
role model
I'm going to get right the first one is
a zero turn when we're going to 4 to the
5 X to the 0 1 4 2 4 1 5 this is
counting down dr. Bob again yeah think
about this with me for a second what
will be the last term in each of these
have a look at this one
I've got up to the third of what were
once one bit you know we got into my no
game over something at 66
by this time with reason became down 6 5
or 3 what or the last one B 0 and then
how many negative X's will I have
I'll have all of them ok in the same way
the last term that you're going to get
here will be 5 C 5 how many 4 zom I have
none of them and how many exerciser with
all of them ok good now you're looking
for the X to the 7 terms what you're
doing is you're not fighting this whole
series of objects by this whole series
of objects okay now what each one is
doing is searching for a part so now
look at these guys
I'm looking to see this guy was like
every single thing here will any of the
pairings that it makes well any of those
parodies result is X to the seventh term
now you're going to look at the powers
you see this color is zero there no X's
here so it's going to have to match up
with the next to the Senate over here
but there isn't one
I ended X plus five so you like this guy
he's done this a bit okay he will not
contribute any X to the seventh I look
at this having X has other one this is
the one
so he's searching pairing up with an X
through the six that will give you an X
to the seventh but if they want answer
though so he's also useless finally yet
to this guy and you are eyes two x's
here if you can pair up with someone
that's got five X's value human X to the
seventh there he is right there you see
that so therefore I have a first
component right the X to the seventh
term the term we only had actually
sevens in it it's going to start like
this it's going to go six six two three
to the four I know it's going to have X
all I'm hoping so I don't get confused
inside okay this one will match up with
this guy
I'm c5 you can see where the X to the
seventh evil occult okay that's one of
them
this guy with Delta Q okay he makes a
pair if you're going to make an
exception with any other term in here
and no because he needs to exact how
they look at the neck so if you get a
fight someone and so yes the one just
before this it will be so he which is 63
three
you execute he will pair up with the
previous term which I haven't written
but I know exactly what I Omega it'll be
five c4 for the 1 X to the 4 okay and
then I'm going to keep going I'm done
with his I will do with the next one the
next one would this guy be able to find
someone to play up with yes it will that
one right so then I'll pair these guys
up that'll be much soon okay this is not
a quick question okay because there are
lots of terms of pair up to make extra
seven you have to include all correct
there exactly right please just solve
all the athletes or more then we just
add it all together and at the end the
code so this is not a particularly led
if I went I would not pose this in the
question because you get the concept but
then just teach attendance to dash out
that I did right and that's not what
we're assessing I'm trying to assess
can you beat the term can you identify
what these things do with each other
like once you've done that I'm satisfied
I have much rather craft a question
we're running a legend for now we can
have this spinning of those to the not
if you get to I can see you know what
you're doing that I'll stop it